Oh, please don't say
anything.
Please just keep
it to yourself, whatever--
[sneezes]
Oh.
Thought you had an idea.
I do.
Fuck.
- We need to make an app.
- Like, for a Smartphone?
An app that all the people
could download and then
we make millions.
It's just, that shit's hard
to come up with, man.
It's like catching lightning
in a bottle.
I already got that.
You got what?
Lightning in a bottle.
Really, what's the idea?
No, no idea.
I got actual lightning
in a bottle.
No, Levi.
That's just a phrase.
I got that, dog.
[static electricity buzzing]
Lightning in a bottle.
Blip.
That's crazy, son.
Where'd you get that?
Some old Chinese man
sold it to me years ago.
I mean, that's some
supernatural shit, man.
Nah, man.
All it does is this.
Oh, shit!
Oh, the lightning!
Oh!
I got it.
[sniffs]
But seriously, man.
Would it be like an app
that reminds you
when your favorite television
shows are on?
No. It--we got to address this
crazy-ass bottle that you got.
What bottle?
Nigga, what bottle?
The bottle with
the lightning in it.
Are you still on that?
Yes. How does it work?
Cedric, I don't know.
It's the classic lightning
in the bottle gag.
Classic li--
You just open it up--
[shouting]
[shrilly]
Oh! Oh!
Lightning in the house!
Lightning in the room!
Okay, you know what?
- You shouldn't have this.
- What?
This shit--this shit
belongs to
the military or something.
But that app, though.
No. We don't need the app.
You've got the goose
that laid the golden egg.
How do you know about Honkers?
[mysterious music]
What?
This mother--
[honk]
Honkers.
Get in on this app idea.
[Honker honks]
- You like it?
[Honkers honks]
- He likes it.
Yep. He got a goddamn
golden egg.
Honkers here is the cat's
pajamas.
[ominous music]
No, please don't. Don't.
I want to show you something.
Whatever it is,
I don't want to see it.
- It's relevant.
- I already know what it is.
It ain't what you think.
Well, what I think it is
is a pair of cat's pajamas.
Yes. These are for Honkers
to wear.
Nigga, what?
The little neck in there.
The neck--
how you gonna fit his head
through this--with the--
the orange pump shit.
[honks]
I'm gonna have to ask you
to leave my house.
Why?
Because you disrespected
my roommate.
Okay. Okay.
It's clear that this is
a crazy house. So I got to go.
You over here talking
about geese and golden eggs
and feline sleepwear.
- [honk]
- Come on, man. Cedric.
You need to get off
your high horse, man.
Hey, I just thought of a name
for you.
♪
High horse.
[neighing]